j'étais au théâtre antoine et j'ai eu
des propositions par franck qui était
directeur de l'athénée et du gymnase et
ses propositions concernant une pièce de
dari bataille qui s'appelait l'animateur
et qui devait ce secret qui s'est créé
du reste au gymnase et un peu avant la
saison après avoir les premières
répétitions
j'avais été joué à lyon bosser les
saints aux représentations
je sais plus quel drame avec la troupe
de là-bas et puis carmen de rési l'émoi
en représentation et je reçois un coup
de téléphone la veille de ma rentrée à
paris qui était la veille des
répétitions a coûté found a requis hier
qu'ils étaient avec moi au théâtre
antoine qui était de la nouvelle pièce
qui était un ami de ma taille et qui me
dit charles surtout rentrer tout de
suite ne soyez pas en retard pour lundi
pour la bêtise ça va mal pour ou alors
j'ai pris un train de nuit qui m'a amené
à paris le matin je suis allé tout de
suite à une heure à la répétition
gymnase et je trouve franc qui me dit
mon vieux ya des choses bien embêtante
vous faites partie du syndicat dit oui
le syndicat venait d'être créé à ce
moment là il me dit bataille ne veut pas
d'acteur syndiqués
à alors qu'est ce qu'on fait 10 le mieux
serait que vous abandonniez la pièce et
puis je signe quelque chose pour la pour
la pièce suivante on peut pas aller
contre bataille je n'avais pas signé mon
contrat avec franck j'avais sa parole et
je lui dis monsieur frank gibeau de
parole c'est comme si c'était signé me
dis absolument je dis bon alors je joue
la pièce de monsieur bataille au matin
il m'avait lui c'est lui les deux
premiers actes j'avais un très joli rôle
le troisième axe je ne connaissais pas
encore puisque j'étais parti qui il
comptait mlle lire aux premières
répétitions je vois bata qui me dit
monsieur je ne veux pas d'acteur
syndiqués dans mon théâtre
alors je dis oui c'est dommage mais
enfin je suis syndiquée et j'ai un
contrat
alors il me dit vous ne jouerez pas ma
pièce pour l'or
pour envisager de me payer mon contrat
et ils en discutent avec franck
et il me dit bon
nous répéterons demain
et le lendemain il m'avait coupé le rôle
en droit c'est à dire qu'il avait donné
le premier axe est le troisième acte un
acteur et il me restait que le l'acte
que le deuxième acte où j'avais une
chose vraiment insignifiante et pendant
toutes les répétitions et empoisonner la
vie façon très désagréable et moi
j'étais en tête-- suis breton et j'ai
dit à chaque fois je joue la pièce du
bétail et j'ai joué la pièce monsieur
bétail un acte au lieu de trois et puis
ça allait comme c'est au bout d'une
huitaine de jours j'ai reçu la visite de
boudry aux qui était metteur en scène et
qui était en panne dans le midi avec un
acteur qui s'appelait pas ton qui
s'était cassé une jambe ici dans les
environs et qui vient me dire écoute il
faut absolument que tu me sauve la mise
il y en a pour deux ou trois jours dans
le midi à prendre entre à paris vient
seulement du tum des pannes je lui
explique la situation je lui dis c'est
pas possible parce que tu sais ça fait
un mois et demi qu'on se bagarre à tous
les jours je joue la pièce tout le monde
me tourne le dos à vivonne debré il y
avait du ménisque et rob gers
jeudi je peux pas et je lui donne
l'adresse de trois camarades qui étaient
susceptibles de
ils ont glacé et le lendemain soir il
vient trop heureux théâtre et il me dit
mon jeu c'est pas possible un tel n'est
pas libre intel ne peut pas quitter
paris en principe avec l'autre c'est pas
ça enfin moi entre temps j'avais
réfléchi je pensais qu'ils m'avaient
assez embêté pendant un mois et demi et
que je t'ai bien fait de manquer cette
occasion et je lui dis coûte
rendez vous demain midi et puis je vais
voir ce que je peux faire et le
lendemain matin j'étais au théâtre de
l'athénée où était le bureau de franck
je demande à loire je rentre dans son
bureau ni qu'est ce qu'il y avait un
vieux monsieur francs que je viens me
faire engueuler dit qu'est ce qui se
passe je dis je veux m'en aller
ça a été un drame évidemment me dis
comment mermoz à supplier de le faire
depuis un mois et demi dit oui mais j'en
ai assez j'ai une belle occasion de
faire du cinéma
alors il faut me laisser partir
il me dit mais bataille acceptera pas
j'ai des contrats avec bata je ne peux
pas changer les interprètes avant la 60e
représentation etc
enfin le soir
grâce à qui hier j'ai vu bataille qui
m'a dit monsieur je vous donne huit
jours ci dans huit jours vous n'êtes pas
revenu vous ne ferez plus jamais de
théâtre à paris il se trouve qu'il a eu
raison parce que réduit jour su rester
un mois à partie et quand je suis revenu
même mon remplaçant avait dû être
remplacé ce qui n'avait pris le rôle que
pour une dizaine de jours et je suis
partie bataille bat [ __ ] à la porte de
brême a planqué sa porte au nez enfin je
suis parti il a eu raison je n'ai plus
jamais fait de théâtre à paris parce
qu'à partir de ce moment là j'ai
enchaîné d'un film dans l'otan tournait
plutôt toi à la fois qu'un seul
lorsqu'il ya une raison
[Rires]
[Musique]